hi I'm Brianna with free code camp and  today we're going to be talking about  the very most basic level the computers  can understand other languages like  JavaScript the most basic thing like  we've already talked about is a bit up  or down 1 or 0 on top of that we've got  the biked 8 bit put together all letters  numbers and symbols can be broken down  into bytes that the computer can  understand the most basic level so that  means all of the letters and symbols  that you're using in your JavaScript can  be translated into byte now there are a  lot of languages that the computer uses  at the most basic levels to run just the  operating system but what I want you to  get away from this lesson is that  everything in your computer boils down  to binary bytes